hello and welcome to the first ever
shaking science show
so the general aim of this channel will
be to talk about science mainly
biological topics as I am a biochemist
but also to delve into you know like the
big questions like what do scientists
thing or what's it like working in a lab
one day so I'll actually be starting a
PhD in a table having just finished my
undergraduate degree so this means I
might also talk about what it's like to
study science at university and advice
for enjoying it and making the most out
of it and I guess eventually talking
about what does it like to do a PhD
because you know right now I actually
have no idea really but yeah basically
haven't quite worked out what their
general aim or focus of this channel
will be but that's what makes the
channel so exciting it could given any
kind of sciency direction at the moment
and and I know that there are lots of
really good science videos and channels
already out there and I'm by no means my
trying to compete with them but instead
I just want to go find my unique
perspective on science because science
or well just life in general is all
about listening and learning from other
people around you and and using that
information to help improve your own
life or to learn something different or
you know it is incredible what you can
learn from other people and I hope with
this channel that I can and give you my
perspective my insights into my world of
science and what science means to me so
yeah I hope that this journal will be
somewhat interesting and I'm that's yeah
a really crap ending I'm gonna work on
my endings but yeah um enjoy it and
thank you for listening
you